oh girl here that we went then you make
a misalignment on the room oh yeah the
Gorske winds came in strong yesterday
started blowing all over the place we
have two days to prep for a video and
we're shooting on Friday two days Clint
is pretty much looks funniest like
physical actor I know of when Joan is
the only person that can play Gizmodo so
we had a couple we can put form begin is
no longer available scheduling was the
challenge so it got pushed the point
that now semen equal our office lifeline
and they're back in the studio all right
or back to two week schedules on videos
it's like this is going to take longer
than two weeks
[Applause]
[Music]
all the character wants to do is just
save people or be a hero but he's
constantly struggling to even use the
soup it's like stop right there I'm
gonna fire missile Aegean fires like the
opposite way on top of the fact I think
the character is really cool and sets up
a lot of like dramatic story beats it's
the fact that he's riding a freakin
wheel first step is obviously getting a
costume our friend John anggee is pretty
good it took them together costumes we
should call him to see if he's even
available dinos he's available today's
video is actually sponsored by audible
if you ever read Miss Warren which is
the same author in fact this book I
think is actually even better the way of
kings the book is met but I'm going to
talk about some really cool things that
exist in this world there are these
swords called
shard blades and personally I think they
beat out lightsabers as the coolest
melee weapon you can possibly have we're
talking like 6-foot blade and yes they
weigh almost nothing you can carry them
with one hand and you don't need a sheet
for them because you summons them but
they're synchronized with your hearts
you actually have to wait 10 heartbeat
for them to show up that they can slice
through anything with your resistance
imagine a wall of solid steel cutting
through is this for razor blade going
through butter the only thing that it
doesn't actually cut anything living
like human in living tissue instead of
cutting it it actually just cleanly
passes right through it but it kills the
organism in the process so if you cut
through your arm and kill your arm is
now great you can't use it you can't
feel it and to expand on that if it
actually has ruined your chest or your
neck and severed your spine your thighs
even ugly smoking stop it for your ID to
be how do you protect yourself from
these blades you wear what's called
shards plate basically an armoured
version of the sword and they look like
imagine like the most epic looking
samurai but like what's glowing armor
because they it feeds on what's called
storm light and it's powered by storm
light which you get from me storm
because they replenish all the drills on
the planet which are acting as batteries
for the storm light it's really complex
that's a thousand-page book if you want
to listen to this book all 45 hours of
it you can download this book for free
by signing up for a 30 day trial using
the link audible.com slash name and ego
I highly recommend it obviously I love
it
and of course audible has an unmatched
selection of audiobooks you can listen
do all kinds of things I listen to
audible almost exclusively when I
commute to it
I was actually recently asked if I was
able to do any short film based on any
sort of work of fiction I would actually
make the prologue to this book I didn't
even talk about the fact that you can
change the direction of gravity
right we are here shooting the we don't
have enough time to explain video I
honestly this Alexis strange is like
coming in fun capitalist don't know
what's going on and there's not enough
time to explain you just got to roll
with it and some part we're going to be
rolling cream all over our faces you'll
be looking on a cream boy more like 20%
cat 80% Gary Busey no no Balin okay say
like that do you look at that they don't
give a clock look around oh we're not
paid to [ __ ] deal with these
filmmakers nice try fellas good your
time machine right there they don't give
up on because people can't really fit in
the fridge every shot of the fridge
going in and out a small tech shop
report
also now if these two guys could just
carry it out a frame and outer frame is
just behind that three you are right
great work all right nailed it and you
tomorrow at the same time as tomorrow
today it is funny with limited time as
make a decision and end up in a
different different space depending on
the decision makers could have all the
time in the world 10:05 tomorrow now for
the main goal here is to make the
costume as cheaply as possible without
looking cheap throw money is disgusting
I don't think I've ever met anybody
who's had that job does anyone who can
do it it's going to be jumped I'm gonna
plastidip when you're making stuff out
of UVA foam right it's flexible and if
you use regular spray paint it's hard
and it will crack and peel this stuff is
made from latex so you spray this on
there and once it dries it actually
bends with the material Niko has not
heard of the idea yet I don't think he
knows much about gizmo duck but he does
know how to make good YouTube videos so
there's a lot of effects work these are
all techniques that I've done in the
past do it well enough and cool enough
but not so much that it will take 5
months to make so where we are now we
have a costume that is been built is
pretty sweet it's in the back I can show
you this our costumes are even built and
completely uh-huh it's completely done
it is all done so we have spent money on
the costume but we haven't see a script
yet I've been so busy I haven't had a
moment to sit down and literally just
like crank out the script I've been
doing a lot of like mental thinking I
got to tell you the kind of cyber
excited so I have a proposal
I propose get a script before we spend
any more money on this project I think
that is fair I woke up this morning and
I died today I get the creme rinse face
let's do one more give us 100 steps and
then give it a hundred I know but God
let's do one more oh my
great nailed it that's first shot of the
day that's we all right that the
creaming is going through the like piece
data as results of this shoe I really
just want to make a video about a dude
with a wheel for legs what's cool about
it is that the character is really
interesting because imagine instead of
Tony Stark you had an idiot I don't know
like someone like Nick you're gonna be
good to push up soon you guys ever talk
about the hacking or the when all the
tiles will change do you remember the
titles that they changed exactly oh go
mine or Nick from video laughing mellow
techno or mine and wait for that one
that's the best thing that could come
out of hack oh this is a serious piece
here and don't cover up the red mark
goes deep there's gonna be some really
intend to make of Iran actually I don't
know be quite ready for the roll oh my
god what are we doing Sam's a good
director though I think you'll get
through it just popped out of a time
machine and you're losing it this is a
serious piece it's pretty pretty
accurate reproduction do it alright yeah
also those are aliens thank you doctor
safety dollar the Vegas dog
and we're in the pad and then I got a
call from Peter all right so that's
quickly surprised when there's a knock
on the door and poked his little head
into the room I thought I wasn't sure if
your head is big or small compared to an
average human type Brent Polk is average
sized human head into the room so you go
sneak Oh guess what this is what he said
I have a script I was script for gizmo
duck and I really it was pretty good all
clear to continue working on the fees
what's up what's cool Sam came to me and
was like dude you got to think of the
craziest video you can do think of a
video it'll probably take a long time to
work on but that will be fine
the situation has changed it got pushed
to the point that now sanity car off of
lifeline and they're back in the studio
it's like alright we're back to two-week
schedules on videos because like alright
we need to shoot this as soon as
possible so we can upload it as soon as
possible on a video that is inherently
incredibly difficult because of all the
extremely effects I haven't even started
the effects for no time to explain
I have no time to do the effects for no
time to explain so it's funnier in my
head
hi okay yeah no dick has no idea I'm
talking about but you yes you I need you
I need your help
he literally mind this or out of his
mind so there's this channel called
Cody's lab but he does is really cool
like science-based videos and he goes to
his mind that he has on property he
minds or above the ground and then shows
you the process of literally refining
that or and making it into a ring with a
little gold bead that he also up and
from there there's like a really cool
video just to see the process of how to
make these things that we take for
granted such as anything made out of
metal gotcha